[Music]
you went out onto the street and asked
most men about their power
most men would look at you like you're
crazy and say you know power me are you
kidding so why is there this disconnect
between the real world of men's power
that still exists in spite of some real
progress and the experience of
individual men well I think it's a few
things one is that when we have forms of
privilege or power tends to be invisible
to us as a man I don't have to think
about certain things I don't have to
think about if I'm 30 years old going in
for a job interview and someone thinking
30 years old he's probably going to
become pregnant even though these days
of course as a dad I'd be an equal
parent there's a lot of ways that men
still have power it's often invisible to
us but I think there's also something
even more interesting and that's what I
think of as the paradox of men's power
the ways that we have defined men's
power the ways we raise boys to be men
come with a set of expectations that
none of us can live up to you know we're
supposed to be strong and powerful in
control you know make money be the red
earner have you know incredibly ripped
bodies like a Marvel cartoon you know
not show feelings not have feelings and
you know we and we punish boys we've
punished boys for showing those feelings
for showing emotions you know boy falls
down and cries and you know we drag him
back up big boys don't cry don't you
know don't be a baby and so we just
pummel boys and men for not living up to
these impossible expectations and
stereotypes of manhood and and yet as
individual men we just assume well
that's what a man is and so there's this
internal dialogue of self doubt about
making the masculine grade and you know
what that ends up being is that men end
up being a bit torn apart and I don't
just mean metaphorically I mean you know
men die younger than
than women because we don't go for help
we don't go to doctors we don't get
emotional support men are more likely to
be addicted to alcohol and other drugs
or more likely to be in prison we're
more likely to commit suicide we're more
likely to die of opiates
you know so all these different things
are the result of a male-dominated
society
it's a strange paradox now can you
imagine designing a world yourself in
which you're half of the species have
more power had more control ran social
institutions random religions ran the
economy and you set it up in a way that
you'd also die younger you'd also have
all these personal failings now there
are some men these days who blame women
on the plight than men are facing
there's some men who say you know the
pendulum has shifted too far men are the
real victims I don't buy it I don't buy
it at all I don't think women are to
blame for the pain the plight that men
do feel they've been brought up with a
set of promises and expectations you
know if you do all these things if you
just suck it up if you just be a man
you'll be rewarded
you know you'll be wor rewarded with
jobs and sex and you know social acclaim
or whatever it might be or the world
doesn't work like that it doesn't work
like that period but it particularly
doesn't work like that nowadays the
world has changed and so men can't just
come along assuming well it's still
gonna just all be in my favor I mean
we've had this eight or ten thousand
year long affirmative action program for
men and that's the way it's been you
know men haven't had to compete with
half of the species for jobs for
positions of power or influence with
that gotten to ruled the roost and call
the shots and the rug has been pulled
out from under that and it's not you
know it's not women to blame not women
to blame it's the society that divides
that whole mess in the first place
[Music]